وسط تكثيف اسرائيلي للقصف على مختلف مناطق
قطاع غزه من الشمال الى الجنوب وسقوط
عشرات الشهداء تحتدم المواجهات على كل
محاور التوغل في مشهد يعكس ضراوه المعارك
وشدتها هكذا اذا وسعت قوات الاحتلال دائره
القصف خلال الساعات الماضيه لتشمل بيت
لاهيه وجباليا وتل الزعتر واحياء مدينه
غزه خصوصا الصبر والشجاع وصولا الى خان
يونس ورفح ليصل عدد الشهداء الى 20000 مع
انتشال نحو 70 شهيد في منطقه الثلاثيني
اما في المعطيات الميدانيه بشان المواجهات
فقد وثقت كتائب القسام حسب الناطق العسكري
باسمها ابو عبيده تدميرها الكلي او الجزئي
لا 4 اليه ودبابه اسرائيليه على مختلف
محاور التوغل خلال الساعات الا 7ن الماضيه
من بيت حنون مرورا الى باحياء جبليا
واحياء مدينه غزه بما فيها الصبر وتل
الهواء الى خانيونس جنوبا اضافه الى
المغرا في المطقه الوسطى واكدت كتائب
القسام ايقاعها 25 جنديا اسرائيليا بين
قتيل وجريح في هجمات استخدمت فيها القذائف
الترادف والعبوات والاسلحه الرشاشه
والقنابل